Dosen für den
katastrophenfallstapeln sich hier
Philipp Nater verkauft Notvorräte etwa
für einen Blackout einen Stromausfall in
Deutschland
seit der Energie-
die roten Linsen schwarze Bohnen
Kartoffelpüree risottreis
Blackout angesichts von Ukraine Krieg
und fehlenden Gaslieferungen ein
Szenario das für viele näher gerückt
scheint
meine Eltern und Großeltern wir hatten
immer den Keller voll mit Gläsern mit
Konserven das wurde eingekauft und dann
wurde das hinten hingestellt und vorne
wurde Weg konsumiert das war ganz ganz
üblich und das eben das ist uns
aufgefallen Anfang der Nullerjahre dass
dass wir das eigentlich überhaupt nicht
mehr machen dass wir eigentlich nichts
mehr im Keller haben das wäre gar kein
Keller haben das
so ist die Ideen entstanden einen
Notvorrat anzulegen sei wichtig mahnt
auch das Bundesamt für
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe
BBK
vorbereiten ja Hamstern und Panik machen
nein sagt energiewirtschaftler Kai Hufen
dick dass wir einen flächendeckenden
komplett Stromausfall in ganz Europa
bekommen der dann wirklich auch mehrere
Tage dauern würde das halte ich für
weiterhin sehr unwahrscheinlich weil es
da eben noch Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gibt
solche rollierenden Stromausfälle
lastabschaltungen das könnte schon
passieren aber ist immer definitiv sie
sozusagen die ultima ratio die in den
Netzbetreiber ergreifen würde
rollierende Abschaltungen kontrolliert
kurzzeitig und regional um das Stromnetz
zu stabilisieren ein sogenannter
brown-out dann ist nicht das komplette
Stromnetz Weg es ist nur in einzelnen
Gebieten kein Strom vorhanden und dann
kann man eben diese einzelnen Gebiete
wieder reinschalten wenn man dann
trotzdem nicht genügend Strom auf der
erzeugungsseite hat muss man
gleichzeitig ein anderes Gebiet
abschalten und so kann man das sozusagen
rollierend durch das ganze Netz
durchführen spart damit
Strom ein die Wahrscheinlichkeit hierfür
sei gestiegen unter anderem weil große
gasliefermengen fehlen
ob es tatsächlich dazu kommt hängt aber
von vielen Faktoren ab wie der
Wetterlage der Erzeugung erneuerbarer
Energien und der Nachfrage nicht zu
verwechseln ist der Brown out aber mit
dem sogenannten Blackout einem
unkontrollierten großflächigen und
langfristigen Stromausfall durch Netz
Zusammenbruch es kann natürlich immer zu
regionalbegrenzten Stromausfällen kommen
zum Beispiel wenn ein Bagger einen Kabel
durchtrennt sowas ist meistens nach ein
paar Stunden behoben allein aus diesen
Gründen ist es sinnvoll wenn die
Menschen sich gedanklich darauf
vorbereiten dass Stromausfälle passieren
können aber das hat nichts zu tun mit
großflächigen mit unkontrollierten
Blackout Szenarien die halten wir für
unwahrscheinlich wie groß ist die Sorge
vor einem Stromausfall oder gar einem
Blackout wir haben uns in der
Stuttgarter Fußgängerzone umgehört
ja man kann da schon leicht Panik
bekommen
aber ich finde es ein bisschen
übertrieben also meistens wird sowas ja
dann auch angekündigt und dann kann man
immer noch einkaufen gehen als ich würde
mich jetzt noch nicht verrückt machen
als ich aufgewachsen bin gab es auch
Stromsperren und so weiter und da hat
man eine Kerze angezündet und fertig
Vorräte aber sollte jeder haben
empfiehlt das BBK für Stromausfälle aber
auch andere Katastrophen wie hoch Wasser
oder Sturm die Checkliste zu finden auf
der Internetseite des Bundesamtes
enthält Tipps zur Vorsorge von
Notsituationen für 10 Tage sollte jeder
Getreide wie Brot oder Nudeln zu Hause
haben Milchprodukte ausreichend Gemüse
Obst und Nüsse sowie Fleisch oder
vegetarische Alternativen und Fette
besonders wichtig genug Wasser konkret
bedeutet das 20 Liter für eine Person
zum Trinken und Zubereiten von Nahrung
außerdem da denkt man auch nicht dran
wenn man keinen Strom hat dann fällt
irgendwann das Wasser dann auch aus weil
ja dann tut auch die Klospülung nicht
wenn es nur ein paar Stunden ist ist es
alles kein Problem aber wenn es eben
über mehrere Tage geht dann wird das
problematisch und das ist das Problem an
so einem großflächigen Blackout beim
Blick auf die Checkliste sind viele
überrascht was da alles drauf steht ja
da fehlt einiges also Milch gar nicht
Fleisch habe ich auch nicht vorrätig
Fette Öle ein bisschen Nudel auf jeden
Fall wie viel Wasser hättest Du so das
nicht aus der Leitung kommt gar nichts
sind immer daheim und Pesto dazu
natürlich
aber mit
Kartoffeln wird schon schwer rot auch
ich habe halt das Glück dass ich den
Edeka direkt vor der Haustür habe und
dann eigentlich immer wenn ich was
kochen will nur über die Straße gehen
und deswegen jetzt nicht groß Vorräte
angelegt habe ich komme aus der
Generation dass wir nicht täglich
eingekauft haben sondern einen gewissen
Vorrat angelegt haben ich hatte ja große
Familie und das habe ich einfach
beibehalten und die haben auch sehr viel
Obst Gemüse selber als ich habe dann
eingedünstet eingefroren und deshalb
habe ich jemanden bestimmten Vorrat
neben Wasser und Lebensmitteln sollte
auch die Hausapotheke mit dem
wichtigsten ausgestattet sein unter
anderem mit Verbandskasten Schmerz und
Desinfektionsmittel
auch Hygieneartikel stehen auf der
notfallliste Seife Zahnbürste
Toilettenpapier und wenn der Strom
ausfällt funktioniert auch der
elektrische Herd nicht mehr dann hilft
ein Campingkocher statt Glühbirnen
bringen Kerzen und Taschenlampenlicht da
gucke ich jetzt mal ob ich paar Kerzen
finde Teelichter habe ich schon zu Hause
also ein Streichhölzer vor allen Dingen
muss ich mir anschaffen Katzen
und Brennstoffe auch ich habe Holz und
den Ofen ich glaube meine größte Angst
ist dass das WLAN ausfällt sage ich
ehrlich auch ja ich hätte ich hätte
wahrscheinlich Angst dass ich kein Licht
habe und aber ich könnte es halt mit
Kerzen machen aber es wäre natürlich
viel schwieriger außerdem sollte man zum
Beispiel Bargeld im Haus haben denn am
Automaten wird man keine Scheine mehr
bekommen
Notfallvorsorge aber bleibt eine
individuelle Angelegenheit schreibt das
BBK natürlich können Sie auch für einen
längeren oder kürzeren Zeitraum
bevorraten das ist ihre Entscheidung
grundsätzlich gilt auch nur ein bisschen
Vorrat z.B für drei Tage ist besser als
kein Vorrat man solle nicht impulsiv
Hamstern sondern gezielt über die
persönliche Notfallplanung nachdenken
essentiell bleibt dabei Wasser und
Nahrung lange haltbar auch ungekühlt für
den sehr unwahrscheinlichen Fall eines
Blackouts in Deutschland